[Music]
all right there's this hilarious trend
on tick tock right now where wives and
girlfriends are sending their partners
into the store
to buy a feminine product that doesn't
exist oh my god that is so
[ __ ] up i should have sent me before i
found out about this i don't know about
this [ __ ] i will straight up do it i
will
this means i take it so seriously that i
will
[ __ ] find out where it is that's like
when guys were sending their girlfriends
to buy games that didn't exist
the one time i because i sent him my
grocery list if he's already at the
store
and i guess it didn't space like usually
i write it list form so there's a return
like it's a new line for each ingredient
and i guess it didn't space properly
and so the garlic and cucumber are on
the same line
garlic cucumber you went around the
whole store looking for garlic cucumbers
god damn right and i was at 99 ranch
i was like i don't [ __ ] know but i'm
gonna find it what kind of ethnic [ __ ]
is this that's
so long like what took so long and then
every time i asked them
hey where's the garlic cucumber bread
they're like they look at me like i was
the biggest [ __ ] that ever lived and
so i was like
i know exactly how these men feel he
came home and pissed at me he's like
they didn't have garlic
i looked everywhere i looked everywhere
i was like well garlic cucumber he was
like yeah you asked for garlic cucumber
you asked for garlic cucumber
and i was like i asked for garlic and
cucumbers
and so she got
you stubborn son of a [ __ ] he's in the
zone i was in the [ __ ] zone dude
thank you he didn't want me to think he
was dumb
if i can't find something in five
seconds i'm asking for help fast
i would come home and say facetime
immediately
give me the [ __ ] too much pride this one
dude sometimes if there's a
if the store doesn't have an item and
i'm like niki's gonna think i just
forgot
i'll take a [ __ ] picture of the whole
show and then she's like
no no i'll be like oh yeah there it is
why are you like don't know because he
he thinks
that i do this that i would like
actually be like no
i don't believe you i'm just very
defensive
i know i would never do that that's
funny all right so okay i want to look
through his camera roll and all
because he's ready to [ __ ] shut you
up but he's never had to use him she has
a whole album
secret butt pics of my butt yeah and a
bunch of empty shelves
just in case you need to use it for ammo
that's exactly right
but i've never asked so dude you should
totally blow these pictures up and then
just like put them on in your opinion so
you're like paranoid of her wrath that's
never coming
uh well yeah that's just poor man are
you traumatized from a past experience
i just don't want to [ __ ] it up he feels
very dumb because i'll send him to the
store for something and he brings back
the wrong thing almost every single time
not anymore
it became a bit because i was like i
just would laugh at him because
how could you continuously bring the
wrong item home
and i'll take pictures but he still
brings the wrong item home because it
looks very similar in his defense
but yeah so i just laugh but he does not
like
he does not like feeling dumb no i don't
like disappointing you
oh that's sweet all right i'm gonna show
you guys this compilation
[Music]
yeah i asked the manager i said do you
sell coach flush
[Music]
i went to the hall and looking for
veggie squeezers
they looked at me i was like
i was like i like that and she's like oh
what does it do
i'm like well i assume i assume it clips
your vagina
vegeta cleaner laughing there was no
such thing
and after like she went in and asked
manager that's the worst spot
everyone's laughing at me they're asking
for
help on the intercom
maybe we should go to walmart
i'm not going to walmart okay really
well go to you you wouldn't think that
thing exists baby yes baby
i'm not getting laughed that again i
don't know what a crush is what is it
tanisha how many listen to all this
idiots saying i'm thinking first of all
i'm not an idiot
she's like is does your girlfriend have
tick-tock by any chance i'm like
that girl tanisha was like excuse me
have we got any more when fresh and
everyone started to laugh i'm thinking
one point i felt like this smoothie oh
[ __ ] man
shut up
exactly sweetie
why would you do that
american men don't fall for this [ __ ]
huh that's what we learned today
it's all british dudes well this was
also posted by a lad bite there was one
american guy right
i don't know i'm just [ __ ] around i
thought we played on this channel that's
epic cousbloosh is a perfect name that
sounds like something that exists
it doesn't sound too funny what about
the vagina cleaner
or something that's too funny to me i
mean poo pourri is a real product so
you never know what's happening in 2000
i think is fake yeah what is the femme
flavor 2 000 is a bar of soap no but
it's the magic fun flame flash 2000.
it has magic and 2008 that [ __ ] was
hilarious by the way
that's a great prank yeah so then one of
these guys
i i don't have the video but one of
these guys actually did get
revenge on his girl with a follow-up
video where he was asking her
to go into an auto shop and look for
blinker fluid
[Music]
it's so funny because girls don't know
anything about cars too so i like really
funny
oh my god the hardest part about pranks
is i don't know if i can get the line
out without breaking
i know you couldn't even do it to your
own mother not one friend fresh i
couldn't say that that was pretty funny
how do you even say fun foreign fresh
like correctly
without laughing fresh magic 2000
what the [ __ ] dude i [ __ ] love tik
tok is such a fun place
you don't stop what's up what's another
funny prank trend that you've seen
oh [ __ ] um i did one but i'll never do
it again
oh fair oh i shocked him with my naked
body
oh yes yeah oh you didn't get the
response you wanted because you're
scared you just scared the [ __ ] out of
me out of nowhere in the middle of the
morning scared him
because he's decent i don't have the
best eyesight i just saw his [ __ ]
i will never be naked again coming at me
don't say blob don't play blob
well not a blob of what is it i will
never be naked again
you can't say nick you can't it was the
way the light is why he has to take
oh no no no no no no no no no
i saw a slender sexual sensual figurine
you were concerned you're like you're
not my wife
you happy necky get out wait but that
could just be another dis
it's okay assistant it's just another
time it's fine i can't help you there
man it's fine it's just another time i
disappointed her
oh geez it's okay baby it went right
back to that longer at least you bought
apple cider once
i did it apple cider vinegar or apple
cider apple cider
he always will buy apple juice it's not
the same
cider has the sparkles no well some does
but
uh cider has like cinnamon and all kinds
of
all kinds of different flavors in it
it's more concentrated you know what's
bomb
the powdered apple cider but if you just
eat the powder
what that sounds really good i've never
heard of it yeah
the the hot one yeah like the powdered
one if you just eat that
and you just pour the powder in your
mouth where did you get that yeah
i feel like you can get go go get it
where the hot cocoa is yeah you can't
i never ate it though that's interesting
dry it's so good
it's like is it like a pes stick like
the the pixies
apple cinnamon pixie stick on them yeah
that's really good but a [ __ ] ton of
powder
you just go like this mm-hmm that's
crazy dude show it to me next time i'm
curious
it's delicious you know what's pretty
good it's
powdered tea like the [ __ ] iced tea
that's already sweet
oh that's good that [ __ ] is so good dude
the lemon tea
yeah just get with the spoon and spin
your mouth what the [ __ ] kind of empty
refrigerator
we did that with lemonade the powdered
lemonade you didn't have regular food or
snacks at home
okay listen that's not okay we know you
didn't
you did the kool-aid without the sugar
yeah no like i i've tried kool-aid
and my whole mouth and teeth were all
right i would just [ __ ] get
my mom would get the country time
lemonade thing and i would just [ __ ]
scoop it and like sneak a little bit
oh and jello jello mix what yeah
oh yeah you could take jello mix and
sometimes you if you drop a drop of
water in it and you kind of roll it
around
it makes like little gum drops you're
hardcore that's smart i know i'm gonna
get judged for this but whatever
i used to also eat dried formula powder
what the [ __ ] that tastes good isn't
that it pretty good no it wasn't
metallicy it was my brother's formula
so like i'd be making him a bottle i'm
like because i would smell it oh i
pictured
i pictured you having isaac and then
sneak in like something like he only had
these guys i can kind of picture that
being good like creamy
yeah it's actually i would smell tacos
and it would smell metallicky maybe it's
a different formula
i don't know and i also used to eat his
barley
like the the you know what i mean yeah
they call it oatmeal
yeah well no that's a different one like
they have different boxes of gerber
one's oatmeal one's barley oh yeah that
thing did smell good
that [ __ ] was bomb i used to make myself
a whole ass bowl of that yeah that thing
does smell good actually y'all are some
[ __ ]
weird [ __ ] it's good you've
never tried never had a good childhood
like we had a great childhood
we were left a tour of advice needed
survival
yo i think that's a latchkey kid thing
right like you raid the kitchen and
explore
with whatever is cause if you had
parents 24 7
in the house they'll be like what the
[ __ ] are you doing get the hell out of
here yeah
but then we'll be like sneaking i wonder
what this one tastes like
or if you have a mom who's addicted to
daytime tv like i did mm-hmm i had the
same experience
yeah you just go in the kitchen big
[ __ ] group hug
also crystal light like a little oh
bro little hint when i discovered
crystal light though
i was mind blown because like you know
how you just put it in your conversation
bottle of water and you shake it or they
had the pop version of it
and then you just drink you're like this
water turned into juice
what the [ __ ] i couldn't eat um oreos
for 20 years
because the lash key kid situation so my
parents got a costco membership
and they got like lots of oreos they got
the six pack of oreos like a bunch of
them
and so i took the oreos and i cut the
cream out of each one
and i was like if one oreo cream is good
i'm gonna make 36 of them
roll it into a ball put the whole ball
in my mouth whoa
i couldn't swallow or spit it out and it
was just stuck to my mouth
and i could i didn't know what to do and
i couldn't get that
flavor out of my mouth forever so then i
couldn't eat oreos can you imagine if
you died of that
that's like you joked on it alone in
your latchkey house
that's literally a youtube challenge
idea you were just ahead of your time
that's true now yeah it's like a
cinnamon challenge right if you did that
and you recorded it
damn one tastes good how many does 36
taste
you